-Welcome back.
We're hanging out with
my co-host, Shawn Mendes!
Now --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Shawn and I are about to
go head to head
in a game of Egg Roulette.
Higgins, would you like to
explain how this works?
-[In sinister accent]
Yes, James!
[ Laughing ]
Here in my hand,
I have one dozen eggs.
Eight of them have been
hard-boiled.
Four of them are still raw.
You and Shawn will take turns
selecting one egg at a time.
-Your accent is so different.
-And smashing it. [ Laughing ]
-From the top of the show.
-I'm a professional announcer.
-Okay, yes.
-Smash it upon the top
of your head.
-Uh-huh.
-You won't know which eggs
are raw and which are
hard-boiled.
But once you choose an egg,
you must smash that egg
on top of your head,
no put-backs.
The first one to smash two
rrrraw eggs
on the top of their head
shall lose!
Shawn.
-Am I picking first?
-Would you like to choose
the first eeeeggggg?
[ Laughing ]
-You really sold "egg."
-[Imitates creaking sound]
-That one looks like it's
kind of hopping out already.
No, nothing's rigged.
-Is this like, the one you
touch, you have to pick, right?
-No, no. You can do
whatever you want.
-The one you pull out.
You can touch all of them.
-Okay, you can?
-Touch my eggs!
-Ohhh.
-Touch them!
-Stop saying that!
Stop saying that
to Shawn Mendes.
-"Shawn, pick me!"
-No, don't smell it!
You can't smell it!
-Oh, yeah, 'cause the smell.
Exactly.
-No, that's me. I had Mexican.
[ Laughing ]
-Oh, that was you?
-Good luck!
-That' loud, yeah, sorry.
I apologize.
He has to perform later.
-So...
-Good luck.
What does it feel to you? Do you
feel like it's hard-boiled?
Do you feel like it's...?
-This to me feels a little raw.
I'm not gonna lie.
-[ Laughing ]
-Go ahead, break it
on your head, bud.
-How would you know?
[ Laughing ]
-Good luck.
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What in the world?
-Oh!
[ Applause ]
-Oy!
-Oh, my God!
-Wow!
-That was insane!
[ Laughing ]
Wow!
Were you wrong! Oh, my gosh!
Oh, my gosh.
Wow, that was
a smash and a half.
Higgins, what happened to you?
A little egg?
-I slipped on the egg.
-Alright, got you, alright.
-Good luck, James.
♪♪
-Now I kind of want to get
that weird one on the end.
Alright.
-It's all over my pants.
[ Laughing ]
-I'm not gonna say anything.
-Get out of here.
-Oh, this, I already know.
I already feel it.
I can tell.
-You can tell what?
-This is already,
it's hard-boiled.
-It's hard-boiled?
-Yeah, I know for a fact.
-Alright.
-Yep.
Thanks so much
for coming on the show.
Congrats on the tour.
What's up, buddy?
[ Applause ]
That's how you do it.
That's how yo do it,
right there.
Come on. You gotta
feel the vibe!
Feel the vibe!
So far you've done pretty well.
[ Laughing ]
Ooh!
-Ohh.
-Are you bleeding? [ Laughing ]
-That one hurt.
-Are you bleeding a little?
Yeah, that's a hard-boiled egg.
-Hit the hair. Hit the hair.
-That one was a rock.
Alright, we apologize.
-That was super hard.
-One is a rock, yeah.
-That was half-boiled.
-Alright, which one?
That one just looks weird.
Why is it like that?
-I don't --
You can't choose that one.
-I can't, right?
-'Cause I know that's cooked.
I smelled it.
I dealt it.
-Goodbye, get away.
-[ Laughing ]
-Oh, no.
I don't feel good about this.
Ahh!
-Come on.
-Why would I --
-Do it hard!
-Ahh!
Dude, I love you.
Thanks so much for coming on.
-Right in the middle.
-Ahhh.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-[ Laughing ] Wham!
[ Applause ]
-I knew it, I knew it,
I knew it.
-The score is 1-1.
This could be egg-cellent.
-Yuck.
Alright, wait. Shawn's turn.
Higgins, why don't we
break it on your head?
-What?
-Where are you going?
-I've got a good feeling
about this.
-You do, right?
You know that it's hard-boiled?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-This is disgusting.
-Alright, here we go.
-You're dripping.
-No, no, no, no, no!
-You don't know, right?
-I don't know.
-Audience Member: No!
-No?
-No!
-One guy just said "no."
The rest of the audience
is quiet.
I feel good about this.
-You feel good?
-Yeah, man. Dude, come on, man.
I do this every week.
-You do it all day.
-Yeah, come on.
-Nothing to it.
-It means nothing to me.
-Right, let's -- Haa!
Ohhh.
-Wow!
You want to go?
You want to see what's up?
We already know that one.
Let's take that one out, right?
Just get it the F out of here.
Okay, good.
Alright, we got this.
Here, look at this.
This is it.
[ Breathing sharply ]
-Two more in there.
-Are we going speed run?
-Yeah, speed, go.
-Ahhh!
Ahhhhh!
Ahhhhhhh!
Ahhh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
The champion!
Shawn Mendes, everybody!
I knew it. I had a bad --
Shawn and I will be
right back after the break.
Shawn is co-hosting.
Come on back.